if you want you can achieve anything
what we tried to do was not thinking
like we were going to fit the island but
can every day double up what we did the
day before that is chef Jose Andres
discussing relief efforts in Puerto Rico
after Hurricane Maria on the Facebook
watch series be fearless his nonprofit
served more than 3.6 million meals the
Michelin star chef story is featured in
a new book that examines what qualities
make a good leader and it is called be
fearless five principles for a life of
breakthroughs and purpose the author is
philanthropist Jean case case is a
digital pioneer and was a senior
executive in the early days of AOL she
is now CEO of the case Foundation which
has donated more than 100 million
dollars to innovative groups trying to
solve social problems be fearless is
published by Simon & Schuster a division
of CBS Jean case good morning this is
perfect and the perfect message for
everybody sort of starting off the New
Year and thinking what can I do
differently what do I need to do so many
good stories in here you write
fearlessness is not the lack of fear but
rather the courage and strength to
overcome it how do you do that well
first of all thanks for having me nor
it's great to be with you guys this
morning so listen I wrote the book
because there are a series of myths out
there about what it takes to achieve
success or breakthrough with something
innovative everyone around the world we
found has ideas about what they might do
to change the world but often they're
stopped by the idea that maybe you need
a special genius or well there are
certain connections or graduating from
the right school our research really
uncovered that actually none of that is
the case and what I do in the book is I
take readers behind the scene of famous
success stories and not-so-famous
success stories to point out that
there's failures and fears along the way
it's just reading the contents page is
inspiring I'm like yes this isn't the
first principle we talked about is make
a big bet and write about or Sara
Blakely of Spanx explain her story
sure well for those that don't know
Sarah's story you know she was home one
day and she had a party to go to and she
wanted the slimming effect of pantyhose
which any woman can relate to under her
pants but she realized she was wearing
capri pants that didn't cover her ankle
and sandals so what was she going to do
with her pianning hose
so she solved her own problem she
decided to cut the feet out of the out
of the pantyhose she was going to wear
and then she realized wait if that's a
solution for me it's a solution for
other women as well
she had no background in fashion she
didn't have an MBA she was selling fax
machines at the time but she took her
idea forward sort of point by point she
went to Neiman Marcus and went in the
dressing room and tried him on for
someone and they made a big order and
then Oprah chose her as one of her sort
of favorite things now one supporters
one of the fears you talk about in this
is the fear of taking a risk yeah which
which everybody has everybody and you in
your own in your own life you were you
were a GE you had a very good job I did
and then you were offered a job at a
start-up and so how did you take that
risk because I know your mother told you
don't do it yeah well really people
thought I was crazy to leave what was
really a good career trajectory at GE to
take this big risk on a start-up but
actually I believed in my heart that I
could achieve more of the goals I'd set
out for myself and make a bigger
difference in the world if I had done it
were you afraid at that point I was
totally afraid to make the leap and you
know what we talked about in the book or
what I talked to readers about is
getting outside of your comfort zone
it's so easy to get locked in a place
where you're comfortable and
everything's ok but it's not really the
life we aspire to I like to say know
things that are great come from the
comfort zone you have to get a little
uncomfortable and push yourself how do
you accomplish being fearless without
being reckless at the same time yeah
well we talked about that I mean first
of all it's important to know your own
sort of capacity for risk some people
are more risk-averse and some people are
more risk tolerant but there's actually
a way you can measure if the risk you're
going to take is one that is measured
and not a reckless risk and I put some
tips and techniques in the book to help
people analyze that it's all about that
special sauce you talk about yeah
exactly
really you read too about about smart
leaders peak around the corners they see
the future but it happens or create the
future before it happened they do and
you know one of my favorite chapters is
fail and the footsteps of giants
yeah because too often we hear the
success stories and we don't know what
happened on the way to success Oprah
fired from television and told she
wasn't right for TV Michael Jordan cut
from
basketball team went home and cried in
the closet Steve Jobs fired from the
very company he found an animal Abraham
Lincoln losing his first two races for
Congress I always told my son it's like
I don't care if you fail it's what you
do after you fell absolutely learn from
it Jesus thank you so much be fearless
goes on sale Tuesday